[Music]
it seems like all anyone can talk about
is the casual clothing we spotted that
Disney Princesses wearing in the trailer
for wreck-it Ralph - we love the subtle
nods to their source materials combined
with some trendy fashion ideas if you
want to pull off looking like a princess
for back-to-school we've got some great
style ideas that can help before we
start back up to school shopping be sure
to hit that subscribe button for more
great videos from the things while
you're at it make sure to check out our
friends at crafty hackers they'll show
you how to make your everyday objects
look awesome now let's get started with
the video Milan not only does Mulan have
a reputation for being one of the most
impressively heroic princesses but her
style blew us away in the trailer for
wreck-it Ralph - that gorgeous eye
catching red silk bomber jacket is the
perfect mix of retro and trendy if
you're headed to the mall and looking
for an awesome jacket of your own
check out this Mulan inspired jacket
available at Hot Topic if you are
looking for another option we also found
this fantastic silk bomber jacket
available at Akira comm featuring an
embroidered dragon don't bring dishonor
to your house or your school by showing
up looking less than fabulous and of
course you'll want to grab a pair of
fabulous red converse just like Mulan is
wearing then all you'll need is a pair
of dark wash jeans rolled up a little
bit at the ankles if you want to add
some more great mulan items to your
wardrobe you'll definitely want to check
out the accessories over at box lunch
comm you can get an adorable coin purse
that looks just like her hair comb as
well as a pair of moulin inspired
sunglasses and jewelry if you're looking
for a stylish shirt to wear under your
cool new jacket box lunch has some
awesome and exclusive options for the
discerning rulon fan Snow White in
addition to being effortlessly casual
and stylish Snow White's laid-back
outfit is pretty brave
after all she almost met her ultimate
demise thanks to a poisoned Apple yet we
saw her wearing a shirt adorned with one
one reason we love being inspired by
Snow White is because she has such a
gorgeous and bold color palette grab a
gorgeous yellow maxi skirt like this one
available at forever 21
Wow
you're in the same store you can also
pick up a bright blue tank top to pair
with your skirts then all you need is
some cute red accessories like these red
suede flats and these dangling red
earrings don't be afraid to mix up this
fun color palette with a pretty blue
dress make the outfit school appropriate
by pulling this oversized yellow
cardigan over this ensemble for those
who aren't afraid of bright colors Snow
White is one of the most fun Disney
Princesses to model your outfits after
if you want to pay tribute to Snow
White's awesome casual wear check out
this awesome poison Apple hoodie from
Hot Topic if you want to really dive
home at the points that you're not
scared of being poisoned you'll also
want to grab this great poison Apple
coffee mug Cinderella Cinderella is a
classic Disney Princess for loved by
many and we even got to see her getting
a makeover right in front of our eyes
even if you don't have a fairy godmother
and a team of helpful mice we can help
you get a great outfit inspired by her
in the trailer for wreck-it Ralph - we
finally got to see our beloved princess
in some formal clothes you can grab her
look by slipping into a comfortable
sweatshirt in that classic Cinderella
powder blue color we definitely don't
recommend running out and buying a pair
of glass slippers but you can add a
Cinderella inspired touch by choosing a
pair that shines try picking up a pair
like these sparkling blue by Betsey
Johnson flats and try not to lose one of
them before the school day is over with
we don't recommend trying to wear a full
ball gown to school but H&M has some
excellent casual options that will make
you feel like a princess if you tend to
get chilly you can top one of these
dresses with a pretty white blazer the
tiara might be a bit much so instead you
can keep your hair out of your face with
a black hair band or their Eclipse tiana
other than in the beginning of the
princess in the frog we pretty much saw
tiana wearing a gorgeous ball gown or a
trapped in the body of a frog but we
loved getting to see a much more casual
tiana in the record ralph - trailer it's
so great to see Tiana embracing her
natural hair texture and it looks
gorgeous on her to add some texture to
your hair try a few spritzes up not your
mother's beach babe soft waves sea salt
spray after all your hair doesn't have
to be perfectly coiffed to look
fantastic if you want to look like
slumber party Tiana
you really need is an oversized green
shirt but we're talking about getting
fabulous for back-to-school here if you
want to pay tribute to the Frog part of
the Princess and the Frog you'll want to
pick up this adorable pair of frog
earrings from Betsey Johnson if you want
the rest of your outfit to be more
subtle
check out these pale yellow and green
stripe wide-leg pants from H&M we love
that they capture the more vintage feel
of Tiana's source material you can give
a further nod to the movie by wearing
this green Louisiana sweatshirt or keep
it less casual with this green sweater
Elsa we're definitely guilty of singing
the songs from frozen way too many times
but we just can't let it go ice queen
elsa is a favorite character for
everyone from little kids to adults when
we spotted her dressed in casual
clothing she was wearing a comfy blue
sweatshirt with the phrase just let it
go we're guessing it's only a matter of
time before you can buy the same shirt
but in the meantime you can grab a
comfortable blue shirt with the iconic
Nike logo on it but if you want to dress
up like Elsa outside of gym class we
have some great options as well
utilizing her preferred color palettes
give your classic denim a break and try
some white jeans pick a fit that
flatters you whether that's a
high-waisted or cropped style like these
pants from Charlotte Russe for the top
you'll want to keep it blue and breezy
like this shirt from H&M if you aren't
afraid to try a more old-fashioned style
check out this cute ruffled blouse if
you're feeling a bit daring check out
this gorgeous ruffled skirt from forever
21 to avoid looking too boho for school
you can pair it with the plain white or
pale blue top Ariel Ariel is another
classic princess who has been capturing
our imagination for years because she's
been in our hearts and minds so long
there is a ton of awesome merchandise
based on the Little Mermaid Hot Topic
has some comfortable and flattering tees
and topped inspired by this classic
Disney film you don't have to break out
the seashell bra in order to get an
Ariel vibe with your outfits because we
haven't yet gotten a good look at her
casual outfit this means we can really
use our imaginations here one easy and
quick way to get the look is to wear
some studying green sequins now this may
be a bit much to wear during the day but
you can totally make it work if you keep
the rest of your outfit casual and
understated if you're going to wear an
eye-catching green sequin top keep
things simple elsewhere by wearing a
plain pair of slacks and keeping your
makeup and accessories minimal if you're
feeling a bit more casual grab a pair of
green jeans from Charlotte Russe then
all you need is a cute purple top like
this one with the subtle seashell prints
from Hot Topic
have fun pairing these with adorable
seashell themed accessories Merida
if you are inspired by the brave
attitude of Princess Merida we have some
great outfit options for you
fortunately you don't have to have any
skills with a bow and arrow to rock one
of these gorgeous necklaces we know were
jealous of Merida's amazing red hair but
a red knit hat is a much more subtle way
to pay tribute to brave if it's too warm
for you to wear one you can bring some
lovely texture to your outfit by trying
out this crushed red velvet baseball hat
from forever 21 luckily for this outfit
you can get away with wearing some
Footwear that is both pretty and
practical
check out these legs of combat booties
from Charlotte Russe pair them with this
pair of Li jeans in the color saddle and
find the perfect green top to go with it
this outfit is perfect for autumn if you
choose a big green sweater one cute and
casual option is this green knit sweater
from forever 21 if you want to go in
another direction you can check out this
cute green fuzzy dress you get the color
palette of Merida with a nod to the
texture of her amazing hair parrot with
some leggings and boots pura put
together look val/val is a Disney
Princess for the classic and gorgeous
color palettes whether you stick with
the blue and write aesthetic or go for
princess golden red you just can't miss
when emulating this princess if you're a
huge fan of Beauty and the Beast you'll
definitely want to pick out this
gorgeous crossbody bag it's designed to
look like the classic rose with the
delicate gold petals try pairing it with
a simple but sweet yellow dress if
fellow Disney Princess Mulan taught us
anything is that a fantastic jacket is
the key to a great outfit for those
taking inspiration from Belle we found
this golden jacket from H&M the fur
lining is even a subtle nod to the beast
part of Beauty and the Beast when
wearing a statement piece like this you
can pair it with a casual t-shirt and a
flattering pair of jeans a pair of red
shoes can give another pop of color to
this gorgeous outfit if you spend a lot
of time
hanging out in the library or you just
want a more understated look try this
overall dress paired with a white shirt
Moana if you love spending time on the
beach Moana is a great princess to have
in mind when you head to the mall
because she's a princess your dress is
more practical than fanciful you can get
pretty close to pulling off a true Moana
outfit try picking up a white skirt like
this button-up skirt from forever 21 you
can pair it with a ruffled orange tank
top like this one from j.crew this
outfit is pretty simple so have some fun
with your accessories
we know that Moana were the hearts of
two feety so you'll be glad to know you
can pick up your very own from a hot
topic they also have some adorable
earrings inspired by the movie Moana if
you're keeping a casual or hitting the
beach feel free to pair this outfit with
a pair of flip-flops or these cute lace
up sandals from forever 21 or if you
want a different take on Moana tried
this fun maxi dress it's a bit less of a
literal interpretation but we're getting
some serious mulana vibes here enhance
their resemblance by spraying some surf
spray from Bumble and Bumble in your
hair Anna she gets less attention than
her sister Elsa but anna is a great
character with impeccable style we love
her casual look from the record Ralph to
trailer and you can emulate these
serious 90s vibes start out with a
casual pair of jeans shorts which is
something you probably already have in
your closet on a pair of this with the
graphic t-shirt with the nod to the
frozen song love is an open door grab
one of your favorite shades of green and
then top with a casual flannel this is
an easy laid-back look that reminds us
of one of our favorite Disney characters
for a less casual outfit start out with
a blue skirt like this one from forever
21 add a black shirt and whatever style
suits you best to incorporate some fun
texture into this outfit grab this
forever 21 wine colored velvet blazer
keep it in style of frozen by adding a
pair of chic black booties
if you're feeling chilly you can also
add a pair of black leggings to this
outfit after all you want to emulate the
style of frozen not actually freeze to
take this outfit to the next level
choose some cute snowy day inspired
accessories to go with this outfit and
that's it for our video but before you
go don't forget to check out our friends
at craft
hackers they'll show you how to turn
objects to use every single day into
epic toys and plenty of other useful
items they recently made a
back-to-school hacks video to help you
get back in the school spirit make sure
you check them out and leave them alike
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
for more feel good vibes from the things
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]